well the boss calls me and he's like
hey man
we like they said they found child porn
on the computer here at the at the at
the oh my god and i'm like
what and they're like yeah they said you
downloaded i'm like who's that what
no like that's insane and he's like you
sick mother and i hang up on him and i'm
like what the 17
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening bro my
anxiety is going through the [ __ ]
roof right now so bro
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast i am your host
david soh if you guys have not listened
to the genius brain podcast before you
are in for a [ __ ] treat i always
start off with an f-bomb because
everybody's like why do you always curse
and i tell you mine you're [ __ ] nuts
[ __ ] i curse because i love it and i
love you very much today we have a guest
it's my buddy brian perry boxing coach
if you haven't been following me on
instagram i've been training with brian
um boxing here and there uh beginning
back in the boxing and i know brian for
how long have i known you now
six years seven
it's been a hot minute dude i think
yeah like um
well maybe five maybe five years five
years it's been a good it's been a good
second
yeah
i want to say
it was yeah it was pre-pandemic yeah
like a couple years before that maybe
like 2018 is when i met you yeah yeah
yeah so four years i guess yeah brian
met me when i literally just started
trying to kickbox yeah
for the very first time yeah and it was
a new experience so he's literally seen
me since day one till now and it's been
a very very long journey so maybe it's
been four years yeah about four years
yeah
because it's been crazy yeah cause i was
training for about a year pretty
seriously you know just trying to get
the motions and then the second year was
just having fun yeah and then pandemic
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was just it's feel honestly it feels
like so much longer yeah but that just i
feel like that just makes your
development that much more impressive
man it's been it's been it's been fun
man i think like
the development wise has been easier
once i started to just
the funny thing is i think i got better
when i stopped taking it so damn
seriously oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah i think i
have i've had that experience too
because it's like i think just like with
anything when it moves from art to like
obligation
it just kills the fun for it and the fun
any kind of art martial art drawing
singing whatever if you lose the fun it
just becomes so regimented and your
creativity goes away and that's the
point yeah you know a lot of people too
when we talk about
you know boxing and kickboxing i'm not
saying i'm [ __ ] good or anything like
that but he is
the idea behind it is like
everybody thinks they have to be great
at something the moment they started oh
totally and they get embarrassed if
they're not good it's like
[ __ ] you just start out for real you're
not supposed to be good not everybody's
a [ __ ] jon jones learning how to
kickbox on youtube exactly you know
these people are anomalies
and i feel sometimes sad for for young
people when they feel this pressure to
be excellent at everything you don't
have to be excellent in everything
sometimes you just have to enjoy the
process yeah right some of the best you
know when we when i first started
kickboxing and boxing i think some of
the stuff that i got frustrated at was
what became something that i enjoyed the
most like for example um just
throwing a across correctly yeah you
know and then when you finally get it
right that process was so enjoyable and
it made it so worth it yeah and you know
when when i get dm's a lot it's like hey
i want to get into boxing how do i start
you go to class and you start yeah
yeah a hundred percent and i mean that
that's the thing though right is that
like you
like you have to be cool with being bad
as [ __ ] if you're gonna get good at
anything like i think that's what it is
it's not even that you have to
like i think if you prioritize
learning over anything else i think
that's a huge that's a huge bump in like
as far as your um
like your perseverance like your
willingness to go through the shittiness
if your goal is just to learn right and
not like knock someone out your your
first day or
beat up everyone in the room or be able
to throw a 360 kick if you're just down
to learn and you keep that
you you'll never hit a plateau where you
feel like you're you're sucking or it's
bad because that's not even that wasn't
even your reasoning in the first place
yeah and some i think one of the hardest
things that um for me was i was so
scared to get hit because i felt that if
i got touched or i got hit i wasn't good
yeah yeah yeah yep
i've totally been there and it's a huge
fallacy because every fighter gets hit
no matter how good you are it does not
matter
you're in the rain you're gonna get wet
yeah period yeah period yeah no and then
that's the thing and honestly that was a
just in my own development as a martial
artist that was a huge thing for me
because i would do that all the time and
it honestly got worse
the better people told me i was getting
it got worse that mindset of like
because then it's like then you go into
like sparring right you go into the room
knowing who are the good guys who are
intermediate maybe who are beginner and
you immediately go like that beginner
shouldn't touch me the intermediate guy
should hit me this much and then the
guys at my level fine it's cool if they
hit me and that's not even the point
right yeah the point is to just do the
thing and the more you do the thing the
better you'll get but i totally know
where you're coming from as far as
and at the end of the day that's what
makes you get hit more right it's
because then you get hit and now you're
in your head and so i think that's what
stunted my growth the most was that i
would just
let's say somebody hasn't trained as
long as me and they would touch me yeah
and then i would get disappointed myself
as how can i let this person even lay
lay a single punch on me yeah but we're
tech sparring he's going to touch me yes
you know yes and even if we weren't and
we were full on going out most likely
he's still going to touch me totally it
just is what i said touching people are
like what are they what are they talking
about
you know but you know
it's funny because
i think like for you you know when
anybody first sees you they they don't
they don't think much of you right
because every time somebody sees
somebody a bigger guy they go oh
this is free lunch yeah all day yes it's
it's so crazy too like when i see you
move because well number one too you're
very like soft-spoken very kind human
being and so i don't expect somebody you
to punch me in the face
you know i was like oh brian's going to
be and then i remember i have a video
clip of it in my instagram of when this
is so funny we're kickboxing right and i
used to be very kick heavy at the time
yeah because i was very taekwondo and i
didn't know how to use my hands very
well and so
i low kick him and i hit him with the
body kick and then we we we gained
distance and then out of nowhere i get a
triple jab to my face
and i don't know what happened
and i look over to nick and nick goes
you're still fighting
you're still going yeah i just didn't
know what happened i'm like did i just
get hit yeah it was literally three jabs
to my face
and i look over and i say what just
happened
right you know
yeah how did you how did you get into
boxing and kickboxing um you know
honestly i
like i had been interested in martial
arts as a kid
i actually took taekwondo from like age
four to six
um and then we ended up my family and i
moved away like to the other side of
town so we never had a car so that
wasn't like a relevant thing
and then but i was always had interest
in it and like even before i had joined
the gym when i was 20 i had friends who
could afford to train
i wonder if one friend in particular who
like over the years became a black belt
in taekwondo then started taking muay
thai we would just spar in the park and
he would just whoop my ass and it was
hilarious because he was like this small
like 115 pound like white boy but he had
years of training and i'm just just me
yeah and he would just whip my ass in
the park and that was my training that
was my training
um
but like uh i think what really pushed
me was um when i was 20 years old my mom
passed away
and
what the up into that point
my mindset was fighting's cool but it's
not realistic like i don't i was always
i was a really really big guy then never
really athletically inclined so i was
like my path is to go to school get a
job take care of my mom
so then when she passed away
in the moment i was just like well [ __ ]
it like i don't have any reason to do
anything else now like i'll just do this
but i think what it really was was uh
me just like coping just coping with the
loss yeah i think that's what it was and
then you know i didn't i grew up without
a pops so it gave me
a positive male figure who
just only said encouraging things to me
it gave me like a community of guys
which was something i wasn't accustomed
to because i was raised around
predominantly all women so gave me a
community of guys who were all
in there for the same goal same mission
um so it just it gave me a lot of things
that i just hadn't had up until that
point it was perfect yeah and you know
like
[Music]
as long as i've known you i've never
really gotten to know you that
personally until recently right sure i
mean obviously because we were training
and punching each other in the face you
know it wasn't like personal issues but
yeah you know there wasn't like these
one-on-one conversations like i've had
with nick and everybody else yeah and
you know your personal life story is
[ __ ] nuts to me
it's it's [ __ ] crazy yeah and and i
say this because you know
i see you as a person and as a human
being and i don't think i would have
ever realized how harsh your background
was growing up because you seem very
well put together and i've seen you know
growing where i grew up too were people
who had your same story but they didn't
turn out the way you did you know
and it's it's kind of like this this the
story of like perseverance and so when i
when you when you talk about your family
you kind of glazed over it like losing
your mom and your father not being
around but kind of like the sequence of
what happened is very interesting and i
think people's personal stories are also
very important to to kind of know yeah
um because
so many times i see on the internet
and
kind of just in general with not even
young people adults now too like people
in our age group millennials who kind of
don't go outside their box to hear other
people's story and it's not to say that
when you hear what other people go
through to kind of minimize or be
dismissive of what you're personally
going through yeah but it gives you
perspective yeah yeah right totally and
so when you talked about your story and
how you grow up like it it kind of blew
my [ __ ] mind so that's why you know i
think it'd be great if you just kind of
tell people like what you've been
through and kind of where you're at now
yeah totally so and then to touch on
what you said about how your perspective
of me kind of like never made you think
i had gone through what i had gone
through it's funny because like growing
up
um
like during that period
in like the years kind of immediately
after my mom had passed away
and i was as i was progressing i would
hear i would get the comment a lot where
it's like you know you could have ended
up in a totally different way or doing
totally different things and you didn't
and that's like impressive
and i just never that never really like
sunk with me because in my mind i'm like
i'm just doing what i'm supposed to do
um
but
yeah so basically uh
man um
really
things kind of like took a downturn so i
lived so i lived in pasadena uh with my
whole family which was at like my mom my
mom and i lived in a back house and then
my aunt
and my uncle and my cousins lived in the
front house
and that was cool that was like from age
4 to 11.
and then we lost that house and that's
where things kind of like took a
downturn family step like our family
kind of like broke apart
um
there was drama that i just couldn't
really grasp at the time because i think
i was too young so my mom and i ended up
living in a motel
because uh she had tried to
um put a down payment on like you know
those mobile homes like the homes you
build and yeah on a lot
and they were essentially what she told
me was they're like well they can't give
me the loan because even though i make
enough money i'm an only parent and if i
get sick i can't pay the payment there's
not enough collateral yeah exactly yeah
we had none we didn't own anything
we'd like been renters our whole lives
or my whole life
so we ended up in the motel and things
still weren't too bad but then
um kind of around the time we got into
the motel my mom was diagnosed with type
2 diabetes
and
she had probably actually had it for a
long time but her body was just
accustomed to such high blood sugar the
doctor when she when she got diagnosed
he was like you should be in a diabetic
coma like these numbers are insane oh
[ __ ] yeah it was i mean i don't want to
say the wrong number because i don't
know the ranges but it was bad crazy
high crazy high
um you know and so we were like okay but
for me nothing really changed on the
surface my mom was just taking insulin
and eating different
and you know she was a bigger lady
and then
over the course of a year she lost
something like 160 pounds holy [ __ ] yeah
she went from being like close to 300 to
like 110 or something like that like a
small small small lady like i never i
did i barely recognized her my mom had
been chunky like me my whole life yeah
and i guess at the time they didn't
recognize that like that was a thing
that can happen to you when you're type
2 diabetic i don't know the exact reason
why but i've heard about it now that
like yeah that's that can happen when
your blood levels get crazy high so they
thought she had some kind of like rare
form of blood cancer
and it was all this stuff right and
i think the
if i had like if i have any regret about
how i was like the year she was getting
sicker and sicker
it was like and i look back at it now
and
i was becoming
sort of like resentful and emotionally
shut down
and i think it's because
the power dynamic was shifting to where
you know my mom you know there was a
point where she had cataracts in both
eyes and was like blind she was blind
for
like three months until she was able to
get the cataracts taken out wow so i
just like had to be home
to like walk her around and like
like it was just my mom my whole life
had been like my sole provider and she
was like this strong almost like
invincible type person
and then to see her kind of like wither
away and become like this really like
sick dependent person it was like
[ __ ] with me bad and i'm you know i'm
going through all this when i'm
17 18. um
and you know like uh
you know there was a time where
she was in the hospital
and she would she had been there
overnight it was like the first time
she'd ever like went for something real
serious
and i was at a card shop in a magic
tournament you know magic the gathering
yep and and like
i
i just i sucked at that game i sucked at
it and
i'm in this tournament and i'm like
beating this guy i'm winning and i'm
like yes
and then i get a call from from uh my
mom
and so i'm like oh [ __ ] so i answer
and she's like i need you to come get me
from the hospital like they just
discharged me and at this time we didn't
have a car
um i'm in pasadena she's at the kaiser
on sunset in downtown l.a oh wow so i
had to like catch the train go get her
and then escort her back
and i got mad
i got mad and
you know in that moment i'm like ah like
i'm about to beat this guy yeah yeah you
know
and i have to leave like this sucks and
like
and i felt shitty about that for a long
time but i think what it was is
it was what i mentioned earlier it was
just the dynamic was shifting and i
wasn't used to having a mom that like
needed me to like
take care of her in that way i mean you
weren't ready to be a parent no you know
i think that's the hard part too and
this is what i'm talking about like you
know you're you had to grow up fast yeah
and it was kind of
honestly sudden oh yeah and when you're
a kid you're not prepared to take care
of your parents right because
your mom your dad your father whoever
your guardian is to you know it's weird
like you know that there's a finite time
that these people are going to be alive
of course but it doesn't really register
no you know you treat them as if they're
going to be here forever and so you know
these small things that feels like an
inconvenience to you it only feels that
way because you're like oh mom and dad
are going to be here forever so it's
like why are they doing this to me yeah
and you know you're super young right
now when you're playing magic again
you're playing your card just like damn
i have to go ahead and take care of this
one when she's supposed to be taking
care of me yeah and it's it's hard to
really think about these things too
because
you know those those things too like i
try not to beat myself up about that
stuff too because of how i used to you
know treat my parents when i used to get
upset about stupid things for sure but
that comes with age yeah you know yeah
pretty sure they did the same to their
parents you know yeah totally um
yeah so
basically um
kind of when things were coming to when
things were getting like real bad like
coming to a head
um
you know her job had like later off
i want to say like three years before
she was getting really sick because they
took like the part of her she was
working in some kind of manufacturing
like for catheters and for johnson and
johnson and they took her wing of like
the company and and put it in mexico for
cheaper work
and so because that happened before she
retired
she had like
another year of pay and benefits and
then her benefits went away we had like
no medical coverage
and uh she had developed um an ulcer in
her stomach like a bleeding ulcer
yeah and so like when you know when
you're diabetic your blood doesn't
really clot that well if at all
and so she was basically
like come to find out after she was just
like slowly very slowly bleeding out
internally
and
um
i
i think at the time it was just like oh
she's just tired she sleeps all the time
she's sick but like we got past it
before we'll get past it this time
and then
uh you know sleeping in the motel there
was just one bed so we shared a bed and
uh
i was gonna go for a run because this
was like i was like tired of being fat i
want to get in shape all this stuff and
i started running
and i'm like alright mom i'm going for a
run and like she just like didn't really
respond and something fell off
so then like i kind of instantly panic
and i put like my ear to her body i
don't hear her breathing there's no like
chest fall of like the breath like the
rise and fall of the chest
i call
like
911
like just panicking and how old are you
at this time 20. jesus yeah 20 years old
and um i like try and turn her over and
the firefighters get there and they like
they attach the um the aed and it's the
there's not even any vital signs coming
back into it
and then and everything happened like
super fast like uh
they contacted the
local mortuary
um and i watched them wrap my mom's body
up in like this white sheet and take it
and uh yeah i just
uncontrollably cried for the rest of the
day how did you deal with that [ __ ] i
don't think like how do you deal with
that i don't think i did i don't think i
did
um
i just i signed up i signed up for
boxing
um and i fell into this really
regimented schedule so
um a friend of mine who lived in burbank
his family took me in because i wasn't
working at the time because because my
mom was so sick
and uh
it was like the perfect schedule
for someone who didn't want to think
about what was going on
so since they lived in burbank and i
didn't have a car and i worked in
pasadena um i would come into pasadena
with them at seven in the morning work
my job nine to five go to the gym train
from six to eight catch the bus home and
that was it monday through friday for
like two years
um
and it was like it was perfect for not
facing any of my [ __ ]
and i think
the reality of how depressed i was came
in when i
stopped working in pasadena and started
working at burbank so then i was never
in pasadena so then my training became
really um irregular for the first time
ever
and i would just
like on my way home from work almost
every night i would stop by the store
get a box of either like bite size
brownies or oreos and like a half gallon
of milk and then just stay up till four
in the morning playing everquest two
jesus dude
eating [ __ ] an entire container of
oreos and drinking half gallon of milk
so so what happened with your living
situation after your mom your mom passed
away and you're there because you guys
were living in a motel did you would you
use days to stay in the motel no so um i
had friends so basically i called i
called one friend they called other
people
and like five or six of my friends
showed up
and they were there with me
and um
my friend gabriel his mom
uh offered to just take me in and like
give me a place to live while i like got
on my feet and got a job
so i was living in burbank i lived in
burbank for almost two years okay um
and yeah that was uh
during that time i think that was like
when i was the most it was the most
apparent that i was like super depressed
like
i'm like a super i'm like a really
social like outgoing kind of guy not
that at all like i just wanted to be in
my room
like work
work was like just sort of a thing i
just went to do i didn't have any
feeling about the job one way or another
and it was weird like
so you know you know me like i i crack
jokes a lot right yeah
and i found myself doing that almost
like automatically like even though like
inside i was feeling
pretty like hollow and empty
okay so here's the story
so the day the day my mom dies
we all go to my friend matt's house um
like a mile away
and we're playing street fighter uh
capcom vsnk2 on playstation 2.
and normally i was the guy that would
give everybody the work everybody right
and so
obviously
for clear reasons i wasn't very focused
that day and so i get beat you know bad
and i go come on man my mom just died
you're gonna beat me in a street fighter
oh [ __ ] and literally everyone in the
room is like
how are you going to be my mom just died
bro i'm just died bro you're not gonna
let me win like damn i'll use that [ __ ]
so much
like we just go out to eat it's like
you're gonna make me split this bill bro
my mom just died yeah for like the next
six years yeah
because i've bro's been ten years uh
yeah i think you pay for the sandwich
yeah you've been at a job yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it was interesting when you were telling
me a little bit about like your mom's
background too because you know i i've
known like i have a friend too whose mom
you know passed away through
you know some unfortunate circumstances
right
and
he went through therapy to kind of deal
with the situation because
i think like he had a lot of like
erratic behavior that he never
really understood why right and we
didn't get it either and i didn't know
his personal story like that i just knew
his mom passed away but his mom passed
away you know she got stabbed to death
and um that's something else
he would never really
talk about his mom whether it was
poorly or whether it was positively or
not he just never really spoke about her
and then we were drinking and we were
talking and then i asked him i'm like
you know how was your mom but because he
didn't really get to know her that well
and i think she passed away when he was
like seven or eight years old
and uh father was never around either
and so
his grandmother uh took care of him
and i was asking him one day and we were
drinking we're a little drunk
and he was like i hate her
i was like oh [ __ ] like why do you well
that kind of threw me off because he was
so young and his mom got taken away
through very bad stuff i was like why do
you hate her it's like she left me i
said she was she didn't leave you like
you know i'm trying to
kind of take it away but what he
after that i think um a few years after
that um he went through some therapy and
then we re-linked up and he was and he
brought up that conversation that we had
he goes you know after we had that
conversation like i never told anybody
about that [ __ ] but then him and his
girl when they got together and he's
married now she asked him to go to
therapy because he would whenever he
would drink he would act very violently
oh and she's like you need to go to
therapy you need to figure this [ __ ] out
and you know for you know anybody in any
culture like but you know specifically
like in black culture therapy is not
that's not it not really it's not it
and for him he wasn't gonna go with
therapy but he found a girl that he
loved and she gave him an ultimatum it's
like do this therapy thing and find out
and he said that he had to come to terms
with
he felt resentment towards his mom
because she he wanted her to be around
and he wished that she would have made
better choices like if she had made
better choices she would still be around
and this would have never happened to me
got you and so he was holding this like
type of resentment toward his mother who
passed away
he just didn't know how to say it in
words yeah you know he just knew that he
hated her he didn't know [ __ ] why
yeah and it was when he went to therapy
he was like i resent her because my life
would have been different i wouldn't you
know you know his grandma was around but
he got into a lot of [ __ ] trouble
because he didn't know to where to put
this anger and he didn't even know how
to put it in the [ __ ] words right you
know which was kind of crazy and
trauma's crazy you know so for you like
when you when you talk about your mom
and obviously there was some very
unfortunate circumstances that happened
too like what is your thoughts about
your mom
i think um as crazy as it sounds i think
uh i'm lucky i'm lucky because
um
and
whatever like this perspective might be
a little dark but
i think um
i used to think that
i was um it just sucked that like i
didn't now at this point i have no
parents and my friends and a lot of my
friends had parents and so like i think
i had resentment in that sense when they
would like for a long time and anyone
would be like would talk about their mom
or talk about
mother's day or buying gifts it would
just like i'd hold it in but it would
like feel shitty
um
but then it's like on the flip side i i
also see that i have friends that have
parents who are like the key source of
their trauma
and like still cause them emotional pain
to this day yeah and that i think like
looking at that it's just like i just
have to be grateful that i have the mom
i had
um and she got to see me throughout my
entire childhood
and that's just that's just what my
story is so like i have to find the
gratitude in that and you know again i
feel lucky because my mom was she was a
saint she just gave and gave and gave
and gave and like
worked herself to the bone and um
you know so
uh
you know my mom she didn't know she
could even be pregnant
so like her first husband
she was or her only husband she was with
him for 15 years until he passed away
and didn't get pregnant once
and then she met my dad
uh like three or four years after that
um
what age did she get married at 17. oh
[ __ ] yeah man so my mom's childhood was
a trip i mean different different time
right
but
my mom growing up um
she was really into she was really into
math she either wanted to be a teacher
or a nurse and both of her parents was
like were like no you're just going to
get married like that's what you do
you're a lady you're going to get
married you're going to find a man to
get married
and she
somehow someway like met her husband
john who
um
she said later she suspected he lied
about his age about how old he really
was but even when they got together
i think he was in his early 30s
oh
yeah man and she thinks that he was in
his like early 40s and he just said that
he was that much younger
but both of my parents were they were
they were like into the idea they like
wanted this guy to like marry my mom
so like my mom
so my grandparents and my mom's side
passed away when she was
17 and 19. her mom passed away the year
she got married and then her dad passed
away two years later wow
my grandma type 2 diabetes and then uh
granddad
she it's like uh
she said she just he just kind of let
himself go he was so depressed about his
wife dying that he just kind of like
laid in bed until he passed away oh my
god that is so [ __ ] sad crazy
crazy
wow so your grandma had also had type 2
diabetes yup holy [ __ ] yeah man it's
[ __ ] wild did they pass away at
around the same age then
i don't i don't know i don't know how
old my grandmother was when she passed
away yeah cause you were you were 20 and
she was 17. uh-huh which is crazy yeah
it's kind of like a weird cycle right
it's strange it's strange like that the
way the timing works out is weird
um
but uh
yeah so my mom went from her parents
like from her parents to her husband and
then from her husband for 15 years until
he died from uh pneumonia
uh yeah
so my mom my mom had a a ton of her own
trauma for sure which is what makes me
cherish her even more because
there was like looking back my mom was
clearly depressed but that never stopped
her from going to work or providing for
me or telling me she loved me or giving
me hugs or any of that stuff
so she was i think that's where i get i
know that's where i get my
sort of like built-in perseverance from
i say it's built in because i don't see
it as me persevering i'm just following
my mom's example i'm just like doing
what i know
you know and that's what she was like
you know she prioritized me above all
else
um even though i came as a surprise you
know because she was with my pops for a
year and then just got pregnant she
never she thought she couldn't get
pregnant
15 years with that guy and it never
happened
holy [ __ ] and so i don't think my dad
thought she could get pregnant either oh
my god he was he was surprised like what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah like hey man yeah you
got here we're having a kid what you
said
you know i don't know what the actual
conversation was i kind of put that
together myself later in my life i was
like wait a minute if she didn't think
she'd get pregnant then my dad
definitely didn't get pregnant you know
so um
and you know he tried like
given
the kind of guy he was in the life he
was living
the first three years he was around
and he tried but he was running the
streets you know that was his life he
was running the streets stealing doing
drugs
um and it was you know and he had his
own trauma with his older brother and
his parents that like i never i had
maybe one conversation with my
grandmother on my dad's side for my
sixth birthday and that's all i ever
heard from her
um well really usually the grandma kind
of sticks around she they're in texas
they were in texas oh yeah that's where
my pops was from he was from texas
and uh
yeah you know i didn't really have a ton
of like so zero grandparents in my life
my really like i have my mom
my aunt my uncle and my cousins that was
my family
my mom was like the person that i really
connected with on like a deep deep level
um
what was my original point yeah so so my
mom didn't even really start like living
her life as an independent adult until
she was 31 32
32 32 years old
wait so
okay she wasn't working or anything at
the time when she was with the first
husband he wouldn't let her
oh that's some old-fashioned
old-fashioned [ __ ] yeah he literally
like she got a job and he went to the
job and told the job that she didn't
need the job anymore and to let her go
this podcast is sponsored by better help
my friends are you dealing with a lot of
stress well guess what there's so many
different indicators of it like
headaches teeth grinding and so much
more even sleeping too little well guess
what my friends have you tried therapy
stress shows up in all kinds of ways and
in a world that's telling you to do more
sleep less and grind all the time here's
your reminder to take care of yourself
do less and maybe try some therapy and
do it with better help because better
help is the [ __ ] i've been using it for
a very long time and they have been a
long time sponsor because i really do
[ __ ] with them better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy give it a try and see if online
therapy can help lower your stress i've
been using better health for a long time
my friends and talking to my therapist
helps me out i do it two to three times
a month and guess what it is a necessity
if i'm gonna take care of myself
physically i'm gonna take care of myself
mentally genius brain listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius
yeah wow wild rice i'm
brenda's rib shack more like brenda's
dick shack yeah
god damn that's what the place was
called i'm not that creative yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so it's like she had zero
independence
from 17 to 32 you know like none none
like really her whole life up until 32.
and so my mom was just kind of like
slapping life together herself and like
from what i from what i hear
you know she was kind of the same person
that i knew her to be when she had me
which was like just a fun loving like
kind giving person she was always that
same individual
um
and so yeah so it's like as i like put
all those things together as an adult
i'm like i don't even know how i like
dealing with one parent's death let
alone two
three years younger you know like that's
just
yeah yeah she she had all of her own
stuff to deal with junior she's still
who she was for me and also too just to
kind of put into perspective like she's
kind of forced she was also forced to
grow up too but just at a later age
because she was kind of held back by her
first husband yeah it's like
so what the [ __ ] are taxes what are
these things like what are the what are
you know credit cards all this other
[ __ ] like she didn't know she probably
didn't know how to do any of that stuff
no like she just knew how to work she
know how to work so she got jobs yeah
and that was everything you know so
yeah even like finances like uh
how all that works i i was having i'm
still figuring it out now yeah you know
that was never a conversation growing up
um
you know i'm sure that's true for a lot
of people so that's not like an added
thing i'm trying to put in there but
just overall um
i just recognized my mom had her own
stuff big time and she did so much for
me and tried and tried to like provide
for me the best life she could
and um i know that that was a regret of
her she felt like that she didn't do a
good enough job
but i think given the given the
circumstances i think she did amazing
you know i i talked about this too in my
podcast before where i um
a lot of people don't understand and
this is not like saying privilege in
terms of like systemic or like the
political sense but there are people who
they don't understand that they have a
leg up
on just some basic [ __ ] and what i mean
by that is that for example you're like
your mom was forced to grow up at the
age of 32 and she was held back by her
first husband right so
the idea is like oh you and i both grew
up in the same country let's say
somebody else right and they go you have
the same opportunities it's not true
what is your what was your life like
growing up right what was the what was
your financial status how was your life
yeah yeah the opportunities are there
and is there to be accessible but one of
the key things that allows people to be
successful is knowledge yep like what
the [ __ ] a credit card how do i build
credit yeah these things aren't talk to
people for number one for people who
don't have money and just don't know how
the system works yeah like for me too
growing up because my parents were
immigrants they don't understand oh i
was i'm an immigrant too never
understood exactly what the whole
schooling system is
right like how do how do we [ __ ]
macgyver the [ __ ] to make it work for us
right what are these what are these like
you know scholarships what are all this
other stuff for we don't know these
things right right but there are people
who have lived in this country for a
very long time who've had like good
lives and they know this stuff they
understand the in and outs of how this
education system works and sometimes
when i talk about privilege it's like i
don't mean it like i said i don't mean
it and it's like white privilege black
private asian i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about the privilege of just
kind of like having people who are
knowledgeable in your life circumstance
circumstance like it really does matter
like in the outcome of our lives yeah
right because your mom just didn't know
yeah right and then how was she able to
teach you these things when she didn't
know what was going on either right all
she knew that i had to work make money
and make sure that i had food on the
table and a roof over my kid's head and
that's her base you know yeah which is
kind of crazy man and like for you after
so you know after she passed away um
you went to go live with your friends
like i it kind of blows my mind just
like
how
something your mom instilled in you was
just
done by her just being herself yeah yeah
absolutely i mean that's kind of trippy
she didn't have to tell you hey no
matter what you're going through in your
life you still have to make sure that
you get these things done yeah right
yeah absolutely and you just kind of
followed her example there was no word
said that was just this is what it is
which kind of which is which is pretty
amazing and i don't think a lot of
people understand that too it's like
leading by example is one of the the
biggest things that you can do for
people in your life yeah man right a lot
of things don't need to be said and
that's why sometimes i get annoyed at
um
you know people that i've met and i see
their their instagram posts and they
they talk a big game but i know these
people personally it's like you know
talking your [ __ ] is very easy but you
leading by people who are around you and
they know you they know you're full of
[ __ ] because you don't ever do the
things that you say yeah you just know
the right [ __ ] words to say and those
are two [ __ ] different things 100 you
know 100
yeah man i think that like with the
the the perspective that i've gotten
about
i think parenting in general and i don't
have kids so i know i'm like speaking
out of my realm but i think that what i
got here's what i have
i have that the majority of the people
i've met in my life um
have positive things to say about me in
one regard or another
and
the
the way i was raised was i was given my
space
and i was 100 positive that my mom loved
me and that i could go to her with stuff
that was really that was really it
like there wasn't like um we never
really
there was like sometimes we would sit
down and talk about
some stuff about what you'll experience
growing up but there wasn't
you know there wasn't like a strategy i
was given or like uh
you know like i just what i had was um
love and space to be myself
and i felt like i feel like now
what that gave me was
a just a really strong sense of self
and
even when it comes to things that i
don't know were like
sort of like uh people's behaviors that
i don't grasp at first my baseline is to
like be compassionate and have empathy
yeah because that's what i saw and i
think with that foundation given to me
as a kid that's kind of allowed me to
grow and understand the world around me
because there's no entitlement from that
place there's no there's no sense of i
should have because i've i've literally
like had nothing
except like a place to live and so
and i've and through that i've
recognized that you can be in that
position and still be a good person and
people will still value you even if you
don't have physical things to give them
or favors to do for them yeah
and i think that was huge i think that
was huge and again just another reason
why i'm super grateful for
the mom that i had man and i wish more
people's
mom i had moms like that you know
because yeah what about you so your so
your dad left you said when you how old
were you so this this is how my pops
ended up not coming around
so basically um
he was around up until i was three and
then i remember it was kind of like it
was spotty and then essentially one day
he stole our vcr and my mom told me he
took it to get it fixed
and then he just like never came back
around
and i think that was my mom trying to
protect me from the reality of my pops
being a thief
so i i so i didn't see him from three
until one day
he just randomly shows up at our house
when my mom is gone at work when i'm 12
years old
and he's like hey brian and i'm like
dad
so you remembered him yeah but he was
like he was really light-skinned because
he had been in prison
oh he was in jail that's why he hadn't
been around oh my god he was in jail i'm
guessing that whole time or some
percentage of that time
so he shows up and i'm like hey
dad what's up i mean he's like how you
been can i come in and i let him in
and he um
you know he takes me to the mcdonald's
down the street we get food we go back
to the house
um he falls asleep on the couch and i'm
just like
all right i'm gonna go to my friend's
house
go to my friend's house he's not home
come home dad's gone
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] yeah like it was the
weirdest it's the weirdest thing he just
like popped up out of nowhere hung out
for an hour and a half and then he's
like okay
and dipped
and so obviously when my mom comes home
from work i'm like hey dad came over and
she's like what the [ __ ] yeah what you
mean yeah like he was here and he fell
asleep on the couch and i went to bob's
house and bob wasn't home when i came
home he was gone
and so
somehow she got a hold of him or he got
a hold of her
and i found out
years later that the conversations you
had with him with him was
um this in-n-out stuff isn't going to
work so either you're here and you're
here or you're not um and he chose not
and so that was the last time i saw him
you know where he's at now no clue no
idea damn he just up and [ __ ]
disappeared out i don't even he probably
doesn't even know my mom is dead
holy [ __ ] yeah i have no idea where he's
i don't even know if he's alive really
yeah you know it's that's what that's 20
years 20 years since i've seen him so
that's crazy yeah man
did you have any like resentment towards
him or you just never knew him so it's
like how can i resent somebody i don't
[ __ ] know
yeah i mean it was weird for me because
i noticed
that he was trying to bond with me in
the beginning
but when i look at it for what it is he
was a guy that didn't want kids and
ended up with one you know
um
and so he was trying to like connect
with me but he was always super distant
you know he like let me taste his beer
one time and that was i think it was a
he had a bottle of old english of course
yeah
if that's classic classic hood delight
that's not the blackest thing i've ever
said still reserved
yeah i'm saying a little mickey's
exactly exactly yeah he's like you want
to try this yeah you want to try this
she's like dad i'm one yeah exactly like
sure well this doesn't taste like milk
and honey yeah your mom's like you
really are not a good dad you're not
like you're cut out of here
bounce yeah you just got my two-year-old
drunk yeah what the [ __ ]
that's crazy dude yeah yeah man so he
was that was that was a weird experience
you know i've thought about that a lot
um
you know because i have uh i've been
i've been blessed with some friends that
are therapists actual therapists
and they're i've talked to them about it
and they're like you probably have some
trauma around your dad
and i was like that would make sense but
i don't
i probably just need to go to therapy
myself um because i don't really know
what to make of it you know i don't know
i don't feel any
anger towards him i mean as you just
heard me say now it's like i recognize
he wasn't expecting to have a kid
his lifestyle was already kind of shady
because what would have happened even if
he was in your life
right it's like there's this terrible
example in your life no the guy was a tr
so check this out man so i have this i
have like this this weird childhood
memory like a fragment of it but my mom
told me when i was two
my dad rode motorcycles
and so what he did his like attempt to
like bond with me
is and it's so funny because she tells
the story like it's so
like nurturing and fatherly but what he
did was he two years old
maybe younger maybe one because i was
like a baby like an arm baby
he zips me up in the front of his
leather jacket and then drives me to the
mountains on his motorcycle
and then like shows me nature as a baby
and i'm like and back then i was like oh
that's crazy how cool but now i'm like
wait a minute that's dangerous as [ __ ]
yeah i could have [ __ ] died
hey you know what let me tell you
something if this if this was uh the
year 2000 this is where my use of the
n-word would come out
i took brian out to the wilderness i had
a pet a wolf
i put brian in the mouth of a wolf what
you think about me now
like you still a [ __ ] idiot what do
you mean yeah yeah
i fed him some pine cones
you know exactly you know that's what i
did for them pine cones yeah like yo you
piece of [ __ ] that's not what you're
supposed to do no maybe that's why your
mom gave them all tomatoes like you
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
and the thing is like when you think
about like the motorcycle crash rate in
california is like 100
and i'm pretty sure no i know where he
went he went to angel's crest
yeah where the baby zipped up in the
front of his
hell a dangerous place to be just
winding roads and [ __ ] it's like you
enjoy that boy yeah you having fun down
there yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you just like look at your mama proud of
himself yeah i'm a good dad but then she
was impressed by it too she was like oh
they're barking because up to the way
she told the story yeah she's like your
dad zipped you up in his jacket you look
so cute he just drove you to the
mountains and i was like mom i was like
that was not okay what
yeah it's like yeah yeah you're going a
thousand miles an hour but i heard that
story when i'm eight so i'm just like oh
wow yeah ah dad if only he stuck around
which is so fun that's like him trying
yeah
yeah
yeah i i
have this like specific memory of him
buying me a uh he bought a whopper from
burger king and then cut it in half and
let me have half
and i think i was three at the time
since before i started school i started
kindergarten i was four
and i remember like arguing with him
that i wanted my own whole whopper and
he's like you can't eat all that you
just a little boy
i'm like i want my old whopper these
weird memories man these weird memories
that just stick out about it yeah
so yeah it's it's strange but again you
know to your point i didn't really
connect with him because he never really
outside of those he was just like the
guy that would come around and like give
me food sometimes
you know like there was holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's super strange it's almost
interesting i feel like it was a bet it
was better that he wasn't around yeah
the guy was reckless as [ __ ] yeah
because your mom was a good example for
you so imagine if he was around he was
your male figure oh i would have been a
punk yeah you would tried to follow in
his footsteps yeah and i had a temper
when i was a kid too so
yeah that would have been all bad that's
so crazy yeah man so it is kind of
fortunate it's a it's it's an
unfortunate fortunate thing that
happened that your mom drew that line
and it's great that she had that
foresight she goes this guy is going to
be a bad example for my son and he needs
to [ __ ] leave yeah yeah and he
respected it he didn't come back around
yeah because there's this idea too and
there's this argument where you know
they talk about
um
having a two-parent household is like
the best for a child right and i think
that's very circumstantial here because
[ __ ] yeah imagine if your father was the
male figure in your life yeah and do
does anybody believe that that situation
would have been better than him not
being around and in my personal opinion
i don't think so no you know i mean i
just
it's like
yeah that whole whatever if you look at
it from like a
whatever sociological or psychological
standpoint of like the percentages say
when there's two parents this happens
but like what about the parents who like
both of them just beat the [ __ ] out of
their kid yeah you know or like just
don't feed them or like
my dad is emotionally unavailable and my
mom is whatever you know what i'm saying
like
it doesn't it's the people right it's
not the presence of the people it's the
people yeah and
that's i mean
my mom was a dope she was like a dope
individual so it's like
that i don't i don't feel like i missed
on anything given the parents i was
given right because it's not like of
course if you could just imagine
yourself with a better dad and then put
him in the slot bro your situation's so
interesting because it's like no matter
where you turn to there's some [ __ ] up
people in your life
like no nobody has your back dude it's
like
i mean you're friends to thank god you
know yeah and that was a that's a
blessing and a half it's like what the
[ __ ] because you what you had your you
had your cousins what you told me which
was a whole other [ __ ] story too
which is which is goddamn nuts to me man
i'm like what in the [ __ ] why is it that
these people like it's like they're
supposed to be your protection yeah and
they keep [ __ ] you over dude i'm
telling you yeah so yeah just to touch
on that um
it's you know it's it's um
growing up so i had my
um
i had my two cousins so my my female
cousin who was
um my aunt's daughter and then my
cousin-in-law who was her husband
and growing up um
i always like love love her and then him
i just thought he was an [ __ ] he was
just a dick for no reason i was like why
does this guy live with us like i don't
like this guy
and then um but it was always kind of
like
when we lost that house in pasadena
things became a bit tumultuous and
my my the female cousin was acting
different
um
her husband just continued to be an
[ __ ]
and so i just sort of like distanced
myself from them
but then there came a point when i was
17 where my mom was just so burnt down
and living in that motel
and they had got they got a hold of a
townhouse in monrovia and my mom was
like look they're saying we can come
live with them like we should just go do
it and i was like ugh i don't know if
this is going to be good but
like you hate it here i hate it here
let's give it a try
and we move in and it was just kind of
like downhill from there
um because you know so i'm 17.
um i hadn't finished high school uh
just because i mean looking back at it i
think just
my mom got sick like as i was getting
into high school
you know because he had diabetes for
eight years
and um
i just like there was nothing there was
nothing that could make me give a [ __ ]
about that place given like what my mom
was going through and what she was what
was happening with her
um
and so i you know i asked her to sign me
out so at the time i wasn't in school 17
maybe moving with them they're like you
need to get a job you need a job you're
going to live here you need to pay rent
and i was like fair enough but i'm like
a 17 year old with no job experience and
no no ged no high school diploma so
everyone's like why the [ __ ] would we
hire you like you know yeah yeah yeah so
i couldn't get a job so then finally my
cousin
gave me a job as a well got me a job as
a security guard working under the table
and it started out cool you know working
a bunch of hours the money was dope for
a 17 year old you know i was making like
800 bucks a paycheck yeah that's real
good yeah that was cool 18 like 17 years
old it was it was fire
you know and uh this is these are the
this is the kind of people like a window
into just how they are
so my cousin my female cousin my blood
cousin she goes hey you know what this
is your first job your first check you
don't have to give us any money just
keep that and enjoy that and i'm like
really she's like yeah i'm like dope
so i go and i get the check and she's
like oh how does it feel making money
i'm like it's great i got 800 bucks
she's like you got how much and i was
like 800 she's like okay you can pay us
just like flipped on a dime flipped i'll
kill somebody yeah
i'm legit i'll kill a [ __ ] dude
i said that was and so that that kind of
continued man and like every
page and the crazy thing is this whole
time they're getting money from my mom
granted they were getting money from my
mom before we even moved in with them
and after we lost that place and ended
up back in the motel they were still
hitting up my mom for money constantly
constantly my mom was giving them money
while paying to live in a motel i will
literally cut these people i'm telling
you
just like leeches just leeches human
leeches i love their kids i love their
kids i like the they're they have five
kids and i
love the hell out of all of them um the
two oldest ones are like they're like
five and six years younger than me so
they've been adults
but they have three little ones in there
i love them i love them i love them but
the their
parents so
so things progress and basically we live
there for a year
and
they continue to take more and more
money from my paychecks as i get them
and uh it kind of comes to like a
boiling point when
uh
we so the way we got paid at this
company because it was so small is we
had physical time cards we had to keep
and you had to fax in your time card to
get paid
and i had misplaced the one i had for
that week and so my check was late
and out of nowhere they're like we need
that money we need that money if we
don't get that money we can't pay rent
and i was like rent what you mean and i
was like what the f and i
at the time i'm like that sounds crazy
but i can't question it
you're like you're getting money from my
mom my aunt at the time
you know so i'm just like what is
happening like this is crazy like what's
the rent on this townhouse what are you
talking about right right and this is
uh 2006 you know in monrovia yeah 2006
2005 in monrovia like a town home that
rent was like [ __ ]
barely two thousand dollars yeah
probably like eighteen hundred it was
probably probably less
yeah yeah
and so um
yeah so they're pressing me they're
pressing me they're pressing me
and by the time i get the check they get
like their eviction notice to get out
and so they're really they're literally
putting it on me that they lost the
house they're like because we didn't get
your check we couldn't make the rent now
you don't get an eviction notice that
fast [ __ ] no so they were they weren't
paying for a hot second they were lately
so leading up to that point right
leading up to that point they're trying
to like
they're trying to get me back because
after they after they lose the place um
and i still don't know what's what
really is going on
i move out of there
i move in with um
another friend who lives in pasadena
and
uh
they're like oh well you still owe us
money for that last whatever that last
time you were here at the uh at the town
home
i finally find the play card i turned it
in i get the check i go back to give
them the money and my at that time
the youngest cousin at the time had just
been born he was like one years old
and i go in and he like walks up to me
and her husband like just grabs him away
from me
like nope like we're not talking to him
and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
like they just like flipped on me they
just flipped like they i became their
most hated person
and it was it literally like
i just it just didn't make sense i was
like how was it that like my one check
was the reason why you guys couldn't pay
the rent when there's
three adults in this house with incomes
and like you're counting on a 17 year
old's check to make the rent like i just
didn't understand
come to find out
uh
my cousin's husband years prior when
they lived in riverside
um had his license suspended
and
um he got pulled over driving my
cousin's car with a suspended license
and so he got like this he got like this
three thousand dollar fine for driving
the car on a suspended license and he
just didn't pay it
and so he had gotten a notice saying
like look there's a warrant out for you
you have to pay it was some crazy amount
of money like maybe
seven or eight thousand dollars like
jesus like you need to pay this in
i think it was like 90 days or were or
there's gonna be a warrant for your
arrest and we'll take you to jail
and so that's that's where like the
crunch for the money was coming from but
um
to sort of sorry i'd like to jump around
in the story so that was there right
and so
them to get me back after they lose the
place
i was scheduled i was the um
my cousin-in-law was my relieving
security officer and my shift was
overnight it was 10 pm to 7 a.m
and so what he did was on the following
shift he just didn't show up
and and and this guard company's little
there's like maybe five of us yeah so he
just didn't show up
and so i'm calling and i'm like hey uh i
called my cousin and i'm like hey
where's ricardo at
and she's like don't worry about him you
just stay there and keep working you
know because we have we have to he needs
to be home to help us find a new place
since you since you didn't give us that
oh my god i'm about to suck this [ __ ]
in her [ __ ] mouth
it's crazy so i'm just like uh okay
so then i call there's gas lighting the
[ __ ] out of you bro you know what i'm
saying
like it's nuts and i'm just kind of in
it and again i don't know all the
details so i'm still like [ __ ] man i
[ __ ] up
and
so i call our field supervisor who is my
cousin-in-law's younger brother
um and i call him and i'm like hey
ricardo hasn't showed up for his shift i
don't know what's going on
and he goes okay i'll call him and i'll
find out what's going on and until then
i'll come and leave you but i can't get
there until like five o'clock
and so i've been at this post from 10
p.m the previous night and it's now like
two in the afternoon holy [ __ ] it's i'm
the only guard there right
so then
they um
uh they call me back they call me and
they're like why'd you call why'd you
call uh paul
and i'm like well i was just trying to
figure out what was going on like i
needed someone to relieve me i can't
just be here all day
you know like i have to come back today
for my next shift
and they're like why'd you why'd you do
that it's none of his business that's
none of his business you just stay there
you need to stay there because this is
your fault you did this
and i'm just like this is [ __ ] crazy
so then i get relieved
finally paul gets there he relieves me
and at this point i'm like i just i i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of there i have
to move
so
um
i uh
this was around the time where i go back
give them the i go to give him the money
he pulls he pulls my little baby cousin
away from me he doesn't want him like
touching me or whatever
and i'm just like okay i guess this is
done
and then
our boss our boss he's like hey why are
you working all these extra hours
and i'm like well
like ricardo told me i need to work
these extras to make up for the money he
missed because he has to pay this
whatever and he's like i know his
financial situation i've been giving him
plenty of hours like i know his
situation i'm paying him enough to take
care of his family and take care of that
money why is he making you work all
these hours
and i was like
i don't [ __ ] know come to find out he
was buying drugs oh my [ __ ] god dude
yeah man
yeah this just giving me anxiety
and it sucks you know what sucks about
the situation too they know your age
they know that you have a certain level
of respect for authority for people who
are older they gaslight you
to the point where
you you just feel guilty yeah you feel
like a piece of [ __ ] and they're
hovering and using this against you
constantly because they understand that
you're somebody who respects authority
so you just go along and as a young
person too the hardest thing for people
to do when they're younger and even
adults even now i'm teaching some of my
friends who are my age 34 or years old
to set boundaries yeah and making
boundaries is [ __ ] hard especially
when you're [ __ ] young because you
don't even have like your own two feet
on the floor yet right solid yeah so you
don't know where to set boundaries
especially when it comes to an adult
figure who's supposed to know better
than you yeah you know yeah yeah god
damn it these people are still alive can
i stab you
[ __ ] man well they're i mean they're
going through their own [ __ ] now yeah um
but yeah man i mean it was it was just
an insane time and then
um
yeah so that whole thing falls apart i
quit that job because like i don't want
to work with him anymore he was going to
stay my relieving officer and so i quit
and then uh
after i quit
like they the the boss and ricardo
they well the boss calls me and he's
like
hey man
we like they said they found child porn
on the computer here at the at the at
the oh my god and i'm like
what and they're like yeah they said you
downloaded it i'm like who's that what
no like that's insane and he's like you
sick mother and i hang up on him and i'm
like what the 17
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening bro my
anxiety is going through the [ __ ]
roof right now so bro
so then they so then they come over to
my house
and they they like try this is after i
quit they try and like scare tactic me
my boss and my shitty cousin
all i can think of is that he was
involved in some way yeah but i have no
idea it's like out of left field bro
so they both come over and they're like
like we don't know what's going on here
but like we there may be legal action so
just watch out if somebody calls you for
information that comes over me make sure
you give them that information they come
into my friend's house that i'm living
with and i'm like yeah okay i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about i
don't know what the [ __ ] that is i mean
my mind is like racing bro my mind is
racist yeah you're seven
okay
it's insane give me a [ __ ] address
i will literally gut these people alive
dude dude it's [ __ ] crazy it's
[ __ ] crazy and it's like
all i can think of is it was just like
a reaction to me like stepping away from
that situation
you know and it's
like
thinking back to it now
like i recognized that they were
obviously having some crazy situations
in their relationship he was using drugs
again apparently i didn't see it but
that was just something my mom told me
so he was spending all this money on
drugs while having to pay off that
warrant
and she just didn't want any of the
family to know about it
out and also during this time this one
year that we live there my aunt my
cousin's mom dies from a stroke
right has a stroke in the bathroom
uh i come home from work one night and
the bathroom door is just like off
you know because it like it opens inward
she had her strogan collapse and her
body was like blocking the doorway and
that happened when i was gone at work
so then
that like that night not that night two
nights later we go to the hospital
and my aunt's just like comatose
like on the
on the bed like
that you know it's like the brain bleed
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah so she was
just like gone basically she was just on
life support and um that was tough for
me but obviously way tough for my cousin
my aunt was like kind of a just a
distant person a little bit more cold so
i never connected with her as a kid
but yeah my cousin was dealing with all
that
kind of already an unstable person as it
was
um clearly yeah and then on top of that
you know she's like she's like shacked
up with this guy who's just like
neglecting his family and like buying
drugs with this money that he's supposed
to be paying off this warrant with
so
that was just like a whirlwind of a year
17 was crazy seventeen was just so what
what happened with the whole thing with
them threatening you and stuff with the
whole child porn thing and literally
nothing
they just wanted to [ __ ] sweat you
and make you feel like [ __ ] that's how i
know it was [ __ ]
that's how i know it was [ __ ] crazy
because it's just like nothing nothing
happened no investigator hit me up no
cops came to the house of course they're
not going to do that because they're
already running an illegal security
business because they're paying
everybody to the table yeah they're
paying a 17 year old to be able exactly
you would just be like well i'm 17 years
old and they're paying me under the
table they're not paying their taxes
yeah they would be [ __ ] yeah it's like
hey you want to play this [ __ ] game
let's [ __ ] but you're 17. who would i
know as an adult you could be like cool
i just called the irs yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah i'll deal with it i'm 17.
i'm young i'm young yeah like i'll
survive like i'm 17 my juvie record will
be erased when i become an adult i'm
good
how about you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
how about you druggie yeah yeah you're
drunky
yeah man yeah me as a 17 year old you
can't do that [ __ ] you don't know enough
about this world [ __ ] no oh my god dude
that's [ __ ] insane dude it was wild
that year was crazy that year was insane
how the [ __ ] are you alive
how are you alive just
i don't know man just lucky have you
kept in contact with them since
so
um
yeah i've seen i've seen my my cousin uh
rosalind i've seen her
um
she i kind of lost contact with her when
okay here's another here's another story
so
the the oh my god
so the final thing that drove the wedge
between my cousin and i was um
so when i was 16 no younger younger
younger i was a kid kid
my mom through her job they offered her
like a life insurance policy
and so
but i guess at the time the the person
to be made a benefactor had to be 16
years old at the time that she made the
policy and i wasn't so she made my
cousin the benefactor and then the idea
was when i turned 16 she would switch it
over
um well
16 and on is when she like got sick
started getting sick and sicker and
sicker so it just never came up i even
forgot about it so then my cousin hits
me up i don't know where she's at
because it's been years now since
um we've had contact with her
all i knew is that she had separated
from ricardo
and she hits me up and she's like hey i
just got a thing in the mail saying your
mom passed away um and it was the life
insurance thing
and
she was like um i she i called her i
called her and i told her so she knew my
mom died but then she got the notice
from the my mom's company about the life
insurance policy
and she was like oh if you just send me
the death certificate i'll send you the
money
and i was like okay so i go
uh my friend my friend's mom drives me i
get the death certificate
i mail it off
and i wait like a couple weeks don't
hear anything back
i call her and i'm like hey did you get
it and she's like oh it still hasn't
gotten in the mail um
maybe go and like get another one and
then send it again right
so then
so then like i'm like okay i'll try but
like i i just i never got around to
sending another one
but i was like maybe just hasn't gotten
there yet
so then i call like uh sometime later
maybe a week or two later and the
numbers changed
it like it wasn't even like a a ring and
then a hang up it was like this number
number's not available like the number
was just gone
and there no money ever came
and so i just i don't know for a fact
that she got the money and kept it
but oh she got the money and kept it
yeah yeah i mean oh she got the money
and kept it that's the only a hundred
percent yeah that's the only thing i
could do i never in my life was so
definite that somebody's going to hell
never in my life have i been like i
could literally look your cousin in the
face and be like damn you're going to
hell
you're going you're really going ahead
you're not really going to hell that's
crazy
yeah it's crazy like have you prepared
it's hot it's hot as [ __ ] down there
like god damn it [ __ ] yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy you think lancaster's hot
man i'll tell you something else you're
so messy i'll tell you how hot hell is
yeah yeah
yeah man so
yeah she kept the money so i just didn't
i was like
just
yeah
at the time i you know that whole thing
went down maybe a few months after my
mom had passed away
so i was just like wow that happened
um and then come to find out years later
like when when i spoke to her
and there's something about me it's like
when it comes to that was just such a
monumentous thing
that like
i still haven't really had like
the guts to confront her about it
directly
because since i don't have proof like i
feel like she would just deny it like
she's that kind of person of course
she'll just sit there and just gaslight
you again it never came how could you
accuse me of something why would you
ever think that i would do such a thing
to you you know i loved your mother your
mother was just like my mother and the
fact that you think that i would steal
from her son
that you are a terrible person brian
yeah yeah yeah and they would say that
and i would slowly sink a knife right
into a [ __ ] gun
and like directly into the [ __ ]
windows of her soul
yeah man but coming to find out years
later what had happened was uh
they just like she was with this new guy
who was her ex-husband's best friend and
like his kids and their kids and they
they were like living in a they were
living in a house
um they were like renting a home out
east somewhere in the empire and just
like blew through the money and then
ended up losing the house somehow i
don't know the fine details but yeah
they just spent it all drugs yeah yeah
maybe
maybe she didn't go into detail you know
it's like i think she knew that the
thing she was talking about was around
the same timeline
so when she was talking about it with me
she like skimmed over a lot of [ __ ]
and the thing about my cousin is growing
up with her
she's like
can be one of the most charismatic like
bubbly
funny people ever amazing cook she
cooked every single holiday dinner that
we ever had when we lived together
um i thought she was dope she was my
favorite in the world
but then as we got older and i got older
she just started treating me real
different
and it got to a point where
i mean the only thing i could describe
it as is bipolar to where like she'd be
cool
and say so my job when we lived together
in monrovia was to my chore was to clean
the kitchen after breakfast and after
dinner every day that was my chore the
whole kitchen
and there was like a speck left on the
stove top
i know this sounds ridiculous but legit
there was like a speck and she was like
you didn't clean the oven and i was like
i did clean the oven she's like no you
didn't look at this
and i was like oh well i missed a spot
but i cleaned the oven like it's clean
there's just a spot no that means you
didn't clean it
no but i i did i just missed that spot
and she grabs the dish shatters it boom
do you really want to go back and forth
with me right now and i was like okay i
will clean the spot
so
and that was she was never like that
when i was a kid she was never like that
ever ever ever i wonder what happened to
her
in her life i don't know like i don't
there's something something happened to
her [ __ ] up for her to be like that
she's good like night and day she'll
just flip a switch who the [ __ ] did i
mean that's so this is like the crazy
thing too man
it's so hard to balance that fine line
between like empathy and then now you're
just [ __ ] with me yeah you're right
because
sometimes people get get this a little
confused they go oh you don't give a
[ __ ] about this person you should be a
little more empathetic empathy only goes
to a certain [ __ ] extent to the point
where you can't keep taking from me no i
can be empathetic i can understand what
you're going through but i can make
choices to not be a part of your life it
doesn't mean that i'm the [ __ ]
[ __ ] now yeah that means that i know
my boundaries i understand my boundaries
and you have crossed that boundary too
many [ __ ] times i understand you're
going through [ __ ] but you don't get to
drag somebody down just because you're
going through your own personal [ __ ] and
that's that hard part because i want to
be empathetic i want to be a loving and
kind human being especially when people
are going through [ __ ] yeah but then
but it can't be to my own detriment
though right you know yeah and that's
the hard part cause like i hear this
story i'm like oh she was so sweet and
then something happened there i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is yeah and you
could try to help that person but they
could only be helped to the point where
they want to be helped yeah after that
you just got to make your own choices
set that boundary in balance totally
that's [ __ ] crazy to me it's wild man
this girl took your money
after your mom died yeah this is money
that you needed yeah oh that would have
made things
it was ten thousand dollars
yeah it was ten thousand that would have
made i would have made everything
different yeah everything right food
clothes i would have been cool you know
i probably would have spent it i was 20
years old i didn't know [ __ ] about money
but like
it would have been something until i got
a job you know yeah
so yeah who knows what i would have done
different but
um
yeah it's uh
if you still keep in contact with her
now
mostly just because of her kids um so i
grew up her her two oldest children um
were like my little brother and sister
and i loved them to death and um i
really i really should make time to see
them more um and then she had three more
kids after them after them she had one
more son and then twin girls
holy [ __ ] yeah she had five kids
yeah she has five kids and how how does
how does um your cousins like deal with
this like they just
they know about this yeah oh what the
money thing i don't know i don't think
they do know
but um
it's their parents you know and like of
course you know like
that's hard yeah and yeah so it's just
i i've never tried to like bring it up
with them i don't want to make my stuff
their stuff
but from what i see from them they like
they feel bad for them you know they
feel bad for their parents because their
parents
are both still not in a good way you
know they're they're still
kind of trapped in the same [ __ ] that
they were trapped in it's like how do
you break this cycle too you know
because now that you're
you know um
they have to kind of deal with this and
unpack the parents that they have yeah
like how do they break that cycle and
they're too they they i think obviously
both handle they're super different my
my cousin uh my cousin ashley she joined
the army was in korea for like two years
she was in germany for two years
she now has like a you know she has a
house with a like a boyfriend and
like they're like doing good out in the
out in a inland empire
and then from what i hear my cousin
richard he's just like kind of just in
his room all day like just depressed he
just goes to work comes home
um i guess i'm saying like this cycle is
[ __ ] endless yeah man it's con it's
just like how do you
unpack this [ __ ] for people like how do
you save these people yeah because it's
just
it's generational trauma it just happens
over and over and over and then you can
only hope that you're a little bit
better than the person that you were
before yeah and then you were you're
right you know when you look at this
situation now i can see why you you
could say to yourself how fortunate you
are that you had your mother for the
time that she did yeah because she she
instilled all these great qualities that
you still carry on today despite all
your circumstances yeah and that's the
hard thing to tell people right it's
like listen you can't always be a victim
of your circumstance right it's it's
really hard to say because it sounds
like i'm being dismissive because we've
all gone through a lot [ __ ] i didn't go
through you went through
[ __ ] i thought i went through
some [ __ ]
let me tell you something whenever i
feel sad i'm just gonna listen to this
podcast again hey you know what not so
bad dude
not so [ __ ] bad
you know i hear you because i had to you
know i had conversations with my cousins
too about you know their parents and
kind of they um kind of some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that they did yeah and they never
understood why
like i can't why doesn't your dad and my
mom get along and they just never knew
like the fine details of things but
because i was so hyper involved and
everything um i knew everything and then
you know as we got older there wasn't
any resentment but i just told them i
was like this is the reason why
your dad
stole money like you're so my my grandpa
was living with us at the time
and
um
just like this like personal drama just
like kind of mishandling money and [ __ ]
basically you know he was lightweight
taking uh my grandfather's social
security checks that we were supposed to
use for him to buy him food clothes
whatever while he was living with us
because it's not a lot of money but we
didn't have a lot of money right so that
could have really helped him out so we
were just kind of waiting around and you
know my dad doesn't really speak english
that well and neither my mom's speaking
english at all so i had to call in to
the office to see what's going on it's
like no we've been sending you guys
checks it's like for how long it was
like years but it was it was to their
address and they were checking they're
cashing that chicken
and that was my dad's last straw he was
like [ __ ] this you know what i mean like
it's not like it's an absorbent amount
of money where it's going to help us get
a leg up it was you're literally taking
money from your own parents from a
[ __ ] mouth crazy and it was just so
money food from your parent's mouth it
was like so
disheartening right and then i i got to
say my piece
finally it was um when my grandmother
passed away and she took care of me
really well because my parents were
working so much during the times that
they were working my grandparents
watched this and my grandma [ __ ]
hated my guts by the way but i still
loved it she she [ __ ] used to beat
the living [ __ ] out of me which is like
another story she she beat me so bad to
the point where my dad didn't let my
grandma see me for
a few months because she hit me so hard
with this like stick
in my face and it barely missed my eye
and so i had this like
wealth and scar across my forehead my
cheek and it just barely missed my eye
whoa and so my dad was like you're done
you're not seeing you're not seeing your
grandchildren anymore that's where the
head movement comes from yeah
it started early
oh [ __ ]
oh my david's a natural
hockey still my ass beat
that's funny yeah
it's like what was your first martial
arts it was [ __ ] ass whooping kundo
i had to dodge [ __ ] like crazy
but then that was like my aunt's mom and
my my grandmother had an aneurysm and
then she also which caused like a stroke
which led to like severe alzheimer's
and so
uh she was left in a home at the time
and she was i felt bad because her
memory would come in and out and i
remember i had to go and check her check
on her at the nurse home during the
daytime because my parents were working
yeah so i checked on her every day and
then i remember just hearing stories
where like the nurses were telling me
it's like oh yeah your grandma her sense
kind of came back a little bit but you
know i wish you guys were here
because we couldn't calm her down
because she woke up and she
she got her memories back for an instant
but she didn't know where she was so she
was crying
she was like where am i where am i what
this is not my home and then her memory
would disappear and then she would be
kind of like in a vegetative state again
and i had to deal with this [ __ ] for
like three or four years like i had to
see her like that and then my uh on and
remember she came in and so my grandma
passed away she
she was at this point like intubated so
she had like um she couldn't eat so they
had to put a tube into her stomach just
to get food in there
and so
my dad can't there's no plug to pull at
this point
you know so there was a point where she
was just brain dead and that we had to
pull the plug and then i remember my
aunt came and this is like i was
watching her being wheeled away and then
i was like
dealing with this and then my aunt she
was hysterical by the way during the
time that she was at this hospital that
this uh nursing home she never visited
her once that's her mom
whoa and so she
was like looking at me she goes you
should have taken care of it better bruh
don't boom
this is like they're being wheeled away
and i [ __ ] started ripping into her
right as the paramedics were here and
they were like my mom my dad my mom was
telling me to calm down i was like no no
no and i'm like cursing her out in
korean that's [ __ ] i was like you
didn't see your own mother once i was
like and now you're looking at her when
she's dead it's too late it's too late
she's dead right she's [ __ ] dead and
you were a piece of [ __ ] like you did
not this is your mother
and then for her later on like after i
said my [ __ ] she was crying i was crying
i was pissed yeah and then i just kind
of like
looked at her and she just she didn't
really apologize to me she just kind of
said like
i just couldn't see my mom in that state
and i was like that's okay you don't
ever tell me that it's my fault yeah
yeah you yeah watch what you [ __ ] say
to me that's [ __ ] weird
oh dude so you know like those those
type of things just like dude sometimes
like the people that can hurt you the
most is your family totally it's like
it's crazy because they have like that
that knife that's so close to your heart
like when they do something bad it hurts
10 times more than when somebody else
does it hell yeah so it's like when i
hear your [ __ ] of like just this this
person who took that money from you that
your mom by the way worked really
[ __ ] hard for yeah it's like dude
it's not just money like that's
something that my mom left for me
in case some [ __ ] happened and it
happened what the [ __ ] yeah
well you're over here married to a man
who has a job yeah like you didn't need
it
how he dealt with it was terrible but
you had money yes yeah yeah like you had
somebody like i you know and it's like
not to not to diminish what the
the beautiful thing like my friends
families did i was helped by a lot of
people and i was super lucky for that
but that i wasn't their obligation yeah
they that was like literally that was
pure i survived on good graces
throughout the entirety of my twenties
yeah that's the way i see it right
because at the end of the day like i'm a
grown-ass man and if they don't want me
living in their house i don't need to be
living in their house right they could
have that no one would blame them for
that perspective
so it's like for me to be in that
position when you're like married in a
house and a food a fridge full of food
and you're like come up yes and the
thing that
the thing that made it really like
[ __ ] up was that like it was just a
continuation
of how she had been with my mom the
entire time she like
prayed on my mom's kindness what i was
telling you how were living in the motel
and she would always just come by with
some sob story as you're living in a
[ __ ] motel hotel
you came from a house you came from your
your in-laws house to come to our motel
to ask for money to get money from my
mom and she would give it every time
[ __ ] man you know what i'm saying what
i'm saying it was just like a
continuation of the
she was like oh i did it to to brian's
mom and i'm gonna do it to brian now too
100
which is so [ __ ] up which is why i
keep way away from her way away from her
and even now you know she'll reach out
to me and it's like nothing but like
sweet loving
kind things like what do you want though
i can't not shake that feeling you know
what i'm saying like when she saw the
the killer queen boxing stuff and the
coaching thing oh that's amazing that's
so great haven't talked in years that's
incredible you know you're doing your
thing that's so great that's amazing
like you see
you i mean you think i have money yeah
you think i have money yeah um and you
see an opportunity you know because now
she's just living off of her kids her
kids are taking care of her that's what
i'm saying and that's the thing too that
that's why i dislike it when people come
out the woodwork and they go i'm proud
of you proud of what yeah you were not a
part of this process yeah you were not a
part of the struggle you were not a part
of anything but misery yeah so the fact
that you come here and you say you're
proud of me proud of what tell me what
the [ __ ] you're proud of right what are
you proud of right you're proud that
what now that i am successful through
all these trials and tribulations that
you want to take from me i don't think
so you're not proud of [ __ ] you're
trying to prey on me yeah and that's the
biggest difference and a lot of people
might think that that's very negative
but i've yet to be proven otherwise yeah
right yeah absolutely and even some
people too they hide some of their pride
by saying they're proud of you with
resentment they go why are you doing
well yeah why am i not doing well yeah
100
and it's it's it's like it's that and
then it's also like you just feel
[ __ ] guilty is what it is like you
just feel like [ __ ] because it's like
all that taking you did and where did it
leave you yeah you know what i'm saying
you're in a uh
the quality of your position is on the
merit of your children that's why like
for me
people know too that when they ask me
for money
there's a stipulation involved right and
i learned this from my dad he goes you
don't ever let people borrow money he
goes you can give it but don't let
people borrow i was like the reason why
is because the moment it leaves your
hands it's not yours
so
it strains relationships it strains
everything yeah so if you give it to
them give it because you know you have
excess and if you lost this money you'll
still be okay yes and so i'll do it i
always tell people look i'll give you
this money
i was like but here's the thing
um i'll never ask you for it but it's on
your merit to give it back to me i'll
never think about it but just know that
when you take that this is a part of our
relationship now
i'm gonna trust you to eventually give
this back i was like and i don't care
how much i was like you can give me five
bucks a month
and i'll still take it
but if you just take it and then you
just never bring it up don't talk about
it
i'm not going to forget that yeah
right
i'll never ask for it because it's gone
yeah but now it's going to be on your
merit to make this right yeah so
like recently somebody just borrowed
money from me and i was like this is
yours pay me back whatever amount you
want per month a dollar 50 [ __ ] cents
i don't give a [ __ ] what it is but i
just need to know that you respect me
enough that you'll return this back to
me 100 and those are the type of people
i want around me yeah you know what i
mean like i i i
dislike it when people do that because
it's it it's not so much a test of our
friendship but it's a testimony to what
who we are with to each other yeah man
you know well yeah because and i just i
feel like
the person asking needs to take that
[ __ ] into consideration too
right like why what brought you to this
point where you need to ask another
appear for money yeah when like we're
all out here grinding we're all out here
doing what we need to do to get money
how did you get to this point where
we're at to some degree on the same
level at least as adults functioning in
the world that you need to ask me for
money i'm not an institution yeah i'm
not a bank it's not like i'm sitting on
five million dollars of investment money
right i'm not a roethlisberger or
whatever so it's like where do you
how did like how did you get there and
then
are you on the up and up was this just a
random occurrence
like what how did you get to that
position because that's in my head
like i why i feel like
i could never ask another a peer for
money
it's because it's like well what i think
the the the cure is for me to fix my
situation to the point where i even
thought about
let me ask david for some money real
quick man let me you know what i'm
saying like because how did i get here
that's
you know i'll keep saying this every
podcast even if somebody gets sick of it
it's personal responsibility i'm telling
you that [ __ ] is liberating like when
you when you when you're able to look at
your situation and say listen what could
i have done and that means you've
exhausted your options then yeah come
yeah but a lot of people don't exhaust
those options no a lot of people too and
i have a lot of pride in ego they think
they're above a job yeah right yeah yeah
so i was like oh i did this job and i
was making this money and now i'm not i
can't go work this job listen
you are [ __ ] broke you are not above
[ __ ] yeah right because i get asked that
all the time they go whoa what if all
this stuff disappears [ __ ]
there's uber
there is doordash there's a hustle
there's a i'll go apply at a fast food
restaurant i'll go apply [ __ ]
anywhere you think i'm above a [ __ ]
job i grew up dirt [ __ ] poor the most
important thing to me is that i have
even had backup plans even though i know
that i make pretty good money i have
backups on backups oh yeah right i'm
like okay well if this doesn't [ __ ]
work out let's say hopefully
like i even think about [ __ ] like i
thought about this the other night i was
like okay let's say all my [ __ ] all my
investments go to [ __ ]
then i gotta lose this place i'll go
move into like a studio we'll talk to i
mean well she makes good one this is in
case she's not here either she leaves me
i go i'll move into a studio if not i'll
live out of my [ __ ] car i'll [ __ ]
work a job here until i can save enough
money get a studio get a room live out
of there and rebuild back up yeah like
there is no pride i don't have pride
because in order for me to say pr that
i'm too proud to work a job it means
that i'm i believe that i'm above
somebody else who works this position
and i'm never in that position yep i
remember my parents first opened up
their store we couldn't even afford the
[ __ ] shelves to put the products on
it wow it was hard my mom still had to
work cleaning hotels and motels my dad
still had to work a part-time job as a
mechanic while we still had that store
while he was still going through
seminary school
it's like
none of us are above a job we just have
to make sure that we survive and eat
yeah
that's all that matters yeah and so a
lot of the times you know i had i had a
friend who was consistently mind you
like this person i lent them money or i
gave them money because i knew how hard
they were working until it got to a
point where i had a long conversation
with this guy and i was like hey
i'm gonna give you this money but it's
gonna come with a lecture do you want
this he goes yeah i was like
you
i'm okay giving this to you and most of
the times when i gave you money is
because it was poor circumstance i was
like now you're not in a situation where
this is i was like
there are so many things that you could
do to make money you choose not to do it
i was like because you think that you're
above a job
i was like i want you to think about
this
you would rather take money from someone
like me who was working his ass off just
to scrape by
and you won't do the same but you would
rather take it from my pocket
you know that's heavy right that's
exactly how do you think that makes me
feel yeah i'm i'm doing [ __ ] that i
don't want to do just so i could keep
these [ __ ] lights on i'm saving up
and then all this money that i saved up
grinding doing [ __ ] i don't want to do i
now have to give it to you because you
want to live a life where you get to do
everything that you want
that's a dope perspective
you put that perfectly i kept that
perfectly unfair is that to someone who
i'm your friend yeah you know how do you
think that makes me feel yeah i was like
he's like oh i don't want to say no you
take this [ __ ] money because you
already asked but this is the last time
i'm gonna give you money yeah and then
after that guess what he started working
figured it out he figured it out yeah
and he paid me back no i didn't have to
ask for ask for it that's amazing i was
like here you go yeah and and it was
it made me appreciate this person a lot
more too i'm like
cool they just needed to hear it they
just needed to hear it now you know and
it was great because it made me
appreciate it more it it it strengthened
our bond and i created a boundary yeah
that's dope no that's super i like that
perspective you gave where it's like
because it's that's the thing right it's
like from the outside
all people see is the success you're
having
right and it's like they don't even take
into account the [ __ ] you did to get
there or where you even came from yeah
right just just you saying like i used
to be poor
that right there tells you i worked for
this yeah i'm not a lottery winner yeah
you know what i'm saying like i i made
decisions i made specific decisions to
put me in the position i am now like
based on my work ethic so it's like i'm
no different than you and if anything
that should be inspiring yeah right it
should be like oh [ __ ] like i really
wish i would have like documented more
of this [ __ ] when i first came here like
i don't remember the exact number but i
always say a random number every time i
tell the story but it was like i think i
know i didn't have any more than like
100 bucks in my bank account when i came
to l.a crazy it was it was pretty
[ __ ] rough man and i just
and then my my parents
you know when i came here i think they
gave me like a few bucks here and there
sure but i was so prideful i couldn't
ask them for money yeah so instead i
just ate the same [ __ ] every day and i
just grinded and then youtube started
doing monetization and then i got my
first check was like 500 bucks wow they
covered my rent my rent was 400. wow and
then that other 100 i had to make it
last the whole month to eat and i'm sure
your appreciation for that 100 was let
me tell you something i love that [ __ ]
dude
you have no idea how many different ways
i could eat top ramen yeah yeah like and
i enjoyed this
yes
yeah
i could whip up a mean top ramen you
know yes sir and that come up is very
important for me because
i always have to be reminded too it's
like sometimes when i don't want to do
things it's like dog
you had a hundred bucks in your bank
account even if that
you know like i had a crooked box spring
bed and i got this this walmart used
desk that was on um
display and i had to disassemble it and
bring it to the house and i had it so i
lived across from my office depot mm-hmm
not walmart i'm sorry office depot and i
had to just bring that over and i built
it i just had this box spring bed that
desk my computer and my camera and
that's all i did i stayed in that room
until it worked
wow you know every day until it worked
until i started getting revenue yeah and
i remember i was doing college shows and
it was like a hundred bucks for a show
and i took it
and i was like just i'll take anything
yeah man you know yeah and those are the
things that helps me kind of like put
into perspective like
be very grateful for what you have and
on top of that not only be grateful
continue to work hard because at any
given moment this could be taken away
totally you don't know yeah you never
[ __ ] know yeah yeah right yeah
absolutely
yeah i think um
[Music]
i think that's a really that's a really
strong perspective you have on that um
because i think one
just the concept and this is something i
like i sort of ran into
switching from
like having a typical nine to five job
to
kind of crash coursing into being a
full-time coach and then now kind of
like playing both ends where like i'm
coaching but now i'm back in a job
to where it's like
most folks
like just the
the
the the idea you have about how the
world works is around like you get a job
you make money
and none of the risk that comes along
with like creating a business or having
a business to have income to pay people
ever inches your mind you're just like i
do a task i get paid
the thing is it's like no but when
you're working for you you do a lot of
[ __ ] for everything yeah everything and
you're getting paid for like 10 of it
yes you know what i'm saying and you
don't factor in like the gas driving to
you whatever your job is driving to your
clients the time people canceling people
hitting you up last minute and you being
like well i need the money [ __ ] let me
get over here real quick like there's
just so there's so much to
um understanding that side of it that
especially i think especially if
someone's coming to you for money
recognizing that it's not like you
you because you didn't even do it in a
traditional way right it's not like you
just landed a dope job because your
parents had a company
or even that you
even even that you went to school and
like landed a dope position right
that pays you a bunch like every single
thing you have you earned it through the
effort of your passion for what it is
you do yeah and i had to reinvest the
money and put it back into things like
people don't understand they go oh you
got this podcast you're making good
money [ __ ] you know how much these
[ __ ] cameras cops right right you
know what these [ __ ] mics cost yeah
man like that first the biggest risk of
this podcast was that i i didn't have
guaranteed ads right like i had to take
a risk and you know podcasts weren't as
popular as it was when i first started
this [ __ ] right right so it was like i
had to take a [ __ ] risk and it was
like for the first few months i didn't
make [ __ ] i didn't make anything at all
crazy you know and then youtube cracked
down i was making zero dollars off of
youtube so i was at nothing on my income
wow and then i took a risk and it it
worked out really well yeah so it's like
there's just a lot of stuff to that that
you know nobody wants to see how
something is made they just want to see
the end product yep and um
it's a struggle like it's always like
listen if i was balling out of my mind i
wouldn't be renting a house right
right yeah i mean i would have bought a
house by now i'm not balling you know i
like balancing my life with work and
pleasure yeah like if i was all work i
guarantee you i could make a lot more
money but i wouldn't be very happy so i
have to figure out what's important to
me absolutely absolutely well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast i hope you were inspired
by that story or maybe depressed
hopefully a little bit of both but you
know um
brian's my current boxing coach right
now we've been we've been doing a lot of
great work if you guys want to hit up
brian for for boxing like i'm telling
you this man is a [ __ ] wizard
i've been helping my game and i've been
cracking people lately
you could tell them where they can find
you yeah so uh i'm on my main way of
reaching me is on instagram at brian
perry boxing coach um and that's that's
pretty much it just hit me up on
instagram shoot me a dm shoot him a dm
get that coaching in he's a great coach
very patient very good um and then
genius brains every jesus brings genius
brain every sunday at 12 p.m uh and
we'll see you all next time peace